[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things were considered I'm Peter Lavelle
Bob Dylan once said money doesn't talk
it screams former Republican New York
City Mayor Michael Bloomberg is proving
this just the sheer force of lavish
spending has made him a serious
contender to capture the Democratic
nomination are we experiencing peak
Trump derangement syndrome
[Music]
Krauss Michael Bloomberg I'm
joined by Magus Malik Abdul in
Washington he's a GOP strategist in
Seattle we have Zach caller he's an
author and media analyst and in Los
Angeles we crossed the Kim Iverson she
is host of the Kim Iverson show
all right crosstalk rules in effect that
means you can jump in any time you want
and I always appreciate it it's a toss
up now I always go to the person that
got up earlier but we earliest but we
have Washington and in Los Angeles so
I'm going to defer to Los Angeles Kim
what what are the prospects of this
candidacy moving forward for Michael
Bloomberg after his first appearance on
the debate stage go ahead Kim you can't
just you can't just buy voters the way
that Bloomberg thought that he could the
way that all of us were worried that he
would do at the end of the day he got up
on that stage and he had no charisma he
looked stiff
he looked awkward he looked like that
strange cartoon of a billionaire that we
see here who's like a cartoon of an evil
billionaire and I think we all just saw
that and it was I just don't think he
has any chance whatsoever moving forward
he has way too much baggage
way too many dark skeletons that are not
even in the closet anymore they're all
out in the open and I don't think he's
going to be able to get get over those
his only excuses are the same excuses
that Trump has but Trump got elected
okay Maalik let me go to you in
Washington but Bloomberg is moving up in
the polls okay I mean I started out this
program I'm quoting Bob Dylan you know
money does scream and a lot of people
are accepting it and that is that is
contributing to his moving up in the
polls here money is a big factor in
politics unfortunately Moloch go ahead
in Washington yeah well there's a song
that's money power and respect that's
what you need in life and in Bloomberg's
case it's pretty yeah I think what we
saw with the last debate where he was
actually in there is that that money
really doesn't matter at all
and this is something that the
Democratic Party actually has to get a
hold on Bloomberg to me he had a
terrible debate performance because
there was a lot of expectations that
this money and the number the amount of
support that he's got and let's not
forget that he's actually getting a lot
of endorsements from around the country
from a lot of black people and it did
not translate onstage last night the
point the different points where he was
hit on his response to why he hasn't
released his taxes reminded me of the
response that Donald Trump gave his
response to Elizabeth Warren actually
hitting him over the NDA's the
non-disclosure agreements what Bloomberg
essentially said was well they signed it
and I just don't think that that's
something that's going to serve him well
and keep in mind that Bloomberg is not
going to be on the ballot and it's as
simple to Super Tuesday so we would have
have I think what four races in
elections by then and Bloomberg won't be
on the ballot and I don't expect him to
do well after the last debate at all
well I agree with Kim no crosstalk we'll
see we'll see this I hear these echoes
of 2016 in the GOP we'll see Zack your
turn here okay I'm not discounting both
of what what you both said but you know
we have to be a little careful okay
because you know the being mandarins of
the universe didn't pay off in 2016 Zack
jump in go ahead yeah well Bloomberg is
gonna need a little more gray matter if
he's gonna want to win over the American
people unfortunately in the Democratic
Party money does get you places and we
are seeing him pouring money into all
types of Democratic causes and
candidates I actually found it quite
interesting how openly he was bragging
about how much money he was pouring into
Democrats at the debate in Vegas that
really raises eyebrows considering all
the pay to play that's been going on in
the Democratic Party including in the
2016 election so I think he really
opened up a few Pandora's boxes that are
really gonna do him in between the NDA's
you know it's like he really made Trump
look good for all the bashing that
people have done against Trump for all
these different reasons over the years
Bloomberg is way worse than all of that
and that
you know I'm no fan of Liz Warren but
that NDA trap that she set him in you
know he really made it very clear that
he does not want that information coming
to light and I think that on its own is
a big problem much less you know the
demands for transparency he's going to
see coming out of this debate ok well
let's go back to kami right we'll see
what the public reaction was I don't
trust the reaction of liberal media I
just don't okay because they're in a
bubble and they talk to themselves and
you know what most of the time they're
wrong we'll see how that goes here okay
let me stay with you in Los Angeles
it's the DNC that doesn't want Bernie to
get this nomination it's quite obvious
that's what Bloomberg is there for so I
mean we can criticize Bloomberg for all
we want and that's fine okay but you
know at the DNC this is their their what
their their rabbit up their sleeve here
and they've there are a lot of Democrats
in the leadership are putting their eggs
into the Bloomberg basket I mean against
it gets a lot more complicated than just
some guy that is wooden on stage and he
didn't care he doesn't care at all if he
gets the nomination or if he wins I tend
to think he just wants to be a power
broker and this is his you know last you
know time in the eighth and before the
sunset because you know he's giving his
money away left and right you could
agree or disagree with the causes but
you know I don't think it's good to
bother him but I'm bothered by the DNC
trying to torpedoed Bernie Sanders again
and I speak as a conservative go ahead
Kim yeah I mean blue bird is not the
people's choice the one big thing you
know and I understand that you don't
trust the the media and especially after
2016 I completely understand that
everybody thought no Trump won't win
Trump won't win and look what happened
so I can understand that sort of
sentiment like oh maybe that's the same
sort of thing with Bloomberg but one big
thing is that Trump resonates with a
populous base and so does Bernie Sanders
populism is here whether people like it
or not it is here you can either choose
left wing populism or right wing
populism but that's what is here in the
base that's the movement and Bloomberg
does not represent the people he is not
speaking for the people he is speak
for the elite so that's why I don't
think Bloomberg is really I think
actually the the sentiment that you're
seeing in the media on Twitter from the
people I think that is actually real
with Bloomberg this time some of the
media is actually resonating with the
actual voters because Bloomberg does
come across the stiff he does come
across as he's the person that the the
elites have shoved on us as the savior
for the Democratic Party what does that
tell us the fact that they've chosen a
Republican yet to be the seeker for the
Democratic base shows us that they have
no respect for the voter they're not in
touch at all they just do not trust the
voters they think Trump voters were
wrong and stupid and we've got to
impeach that guy for years and years
we've got to try to get the guy out of
office because the voters were wrong and
they're now trying to tell us the voting
base on the Democratic side that we're
wrong as well yeah liking Bernie is a
problem that we've got to go after their
buddy the billionaire you know Malik you
know they but the DNC changed the rules
again they you know they changed the
rules of the game they move the
goalposts okay they they let Bloomberg
on that stage it wasn't Bloomberg
himself it was a DNC that did that what
does that say about the DNC in your mind
go ahead
the DNC definitely deserves criticism
for this and if you look at candidates
like you know I'm senator Booker and
senator Harris and you know Castro the
problem that the DNC has is that it
seems pretty clear that they changed the
rules to benefit Mike Bloomberg and he
did not do well last night which will be
a problem I think moving forward what
Democrats are going to have to contend
with is similar to what they're going to
have to contend with in 2016 the the the
movement the momentum the energy is
behind Bernie Sanders Bloomberg
unfortunately for Democrats it's not
that candidate I can't imagine anyone
who looked at Bloomberg's performance
last night and said that they felt
inspired and if you can imagine
Bloomberg being on stage with a Donald
Trump arguing that I'm a better
billionaire than you oh yeah it's the
most you're gonna be able to sting
you could sell tickets because that will
be a show of a lifetime absolutely
absolutely you know it will definitely
be a show exactly what has happened to
the quote-unquote moderates okay you
know Joe Amy and Pete you know what is
the Bloomberg effect had on them go
ahead Zack yeah that's a great question
I think that a lot of Democrats are
really concerned about electability
which you know is getting him nowhere in
general but that you know it does seem
probably that Bloomberg has the type of
apparatus they have the type of finances
that could build a campaign that could
beat Trump in November now that's
probably gonna hurt you know Joe Biden
Amy Klobuchar Pete the cheat whatever
Budaj edge that will hurt them because
they you know they don't have the type
of media address to say Wall Street does
Wall Street Pete will work I think okay
Wall Street Pete I've got so many
nicknames form in my head budahas yeah
but yeah you know it will you know
really hurt them in terms of you know
viability and Bloomberg himself isn't
that viable he's just got a big ship and
he's you know throwing money anywhere he
possibly can people are taking it so
it's it's not gonna help them and it
actually was pretty amazing to see the
Democrats really eating each other alive
in the debate in Vegas you know we
haven't seen that type of thing I mean
most of former Democrats I myself a
former Democrat remember 2016 very
clearly when the Democratic debates were
limited to two candidates Hillary
Clinton basically bought the the
nomination herself Bernie Sanders was
completely shut out we're expecting to
see the same thing this time which is
why probably most independents have
already left the Democratic Party and
Goodluck birdie you know it's like he is
some of the things he's still saying are
still relevant but the other half you
know he blamed Russia for rigging the
election in 2016 still when we all saw
with our own two eyes it pulled out from
under him by the same crooked DNC that
hasn't reformed in any significant way
since they pulled it out from under him
in 2016 I mean I'm gonna go to Kim Kim
finishes over 40 seconds for this block
go ahead finish up I don't know if the
Democrats want somebody who's electable
they keep talking about elec
ability then you've got to go with the
people who the people want the people
are the ones who have to actually cast
the votes as much as the elites would
love to in the general election have
super-delegates they don't get super
votes when it comes to battling Trump
out in November
it really will come down to who has the
fire underneath them who are the people
motivated by and I think it's a really
sad thing when actually when you go back
to 2016 Hillary Clinton had a much
greater movement behind her if you want
to call it that Bernie Sanders clearly
had the movement he clearly had the fire
but Hillary Clinton actually had quite a
bit of people who were really inspired
by her they wanted a female president
and you have more than you can around
these other team hold that thought we're
gonna go to a short break and after that
short break we'll continue our
discussion on Michael Bloomberg stay
with our team welcome back to crosstalk
where all things are considered I'm
Peter LaBelle dramatic we're discussing
Michael Bloomberg
[Music]
okay Maalik explain to me who you think
the Bloomberg voter is how would you
describe is describe that voter go ahead
as it seems the Bloomberg voter is
anyone who's in need of money I'm in
Washington no I'm not talking about the
consultants not talking about the
consultants okay no there plenty of
consultants Bloomberg their grandmother
off a clip okay I met these people I'm
not talking about consultant I'm talking
about voters go ahead you know I I that
that's a very good question if I had to
guess I would say that the Bloomberg
voters are those who believe that Trump
needs to be beaten by any exactly Mary
word ends up being that person yeah
Bloomberg ends up being that person
they'll be happy with that but you know
as Kim and Zack you know as we were
saying there's no energy behind
Bloomberg and so what will happen yeah I
think is similar to what will happen in
2016 what the Democrats need to the
Democratic partner needs to be careful
is that if they're pushing Bernie out to
elevate Bloomberg as if he's going to
rise like the Phoenix like from the
ashes like the Phoenix and he doesn't
really deliver in these debate
performances it's going to be a really
big problem and one thing that we have
to be mindful of is that in November
there could be a depressed vote on the
Democrat side simply because there
there's no energy behind Bloomberg other
than the ones who have taken his $6,500
checks here and there but he is not a
candidate that's inspiring and I think
that's going to be the problem for
Bloomberg he's a dud
he's a dud as a candidate but he's a
rich dud Zach he's a very rich dud and
he last polling net nationwide polling
15% you know and Bernie's ret around 31
I mean money buys a lot of things okay
but you know we already brought up I
said it in my introduction you know
Trump derangement syndrome people might
be interested in Michael Bloomberg
simply for that reason but Zack what
happens now and it our whole
conversation is going to prove my
point here we're talking about Bloomberg
and Bernie Sanders everybody else has
been deleted okay now we'll have the
next few months until the convention
it's gonna be this slugfest between
these two and Bernie will win okay and
and what that does is it and I agree
with Malik what he just said it's gonna
be voter suppression it's gonna be
people gonna say why go vote okay this
the DNC has screwed up again
big-time Zac completely agree yet the
DNC you know we're really gonna see this
cycle how much money can buy you know
last time Hillary Clinton had the whole
you know corporate duopoly behind her so
she really did have a huge machine
she'd been preparing for years for that
election Bloomberg not the same he's
pouring as much money in we're watching
the money burn which is fun you know I'm
thinking who is a Bloomberg voter does
he even have one yet mr. burns from the
Simpson can't vote so I'm not even sure
that he'll have any votes and can made a
great point you can buy support in the
primaries but you can't buy support in
the general election so the Democrats
again completely short-sighted they're
trying to submit an alternative that's
not Bernie since they clearly did as
much as they could last time to stop
Bernie from getting the nomination
they're trying it with Bloomberg he's
basically a skeleton up there and we're
gonna see how much money can't do this
time and it's gonna be really
interesting to see how it plays out
because it does seem like Bernie should
get the nomination given the momentum
but the Democratic Party that's the last
thing they want there's so much
infighting still between the Sanders
camp and the former Clinton camp the
former Obama camp I mean what is the are
the next is gonna be run by Robbie
mooks caucus app we're gonna find the
results two weeks later in a puerto
rican warehouse there's gonna be devoted
that bloomberg is gonna get there's
really interests there is real meddling
there there's real meddling there with
robbie there that's that's like we can
prove that empirically okay can me
explain to me what's going on Bernie's
not even a Democrat he's a socialist and
Bloomberg really is MIT Democrat he's a
Republican how did the Democrats find
themselves in this situation is
Democrat the rest of them are not the
rest of them are just corporate bought
out pantsuits that are not supportive or
representative of the American people
anymore Bernie Sanders is the true
Democrat Mike Bloomberg is an actual
Republican who somehow decided to switch
parties because that's how easy it is to
do that that's what it takes you just so
now I'm a Democrat and now he's claiming
to be one I think really what's happened
here is that Bernie Sanders is clearly a
threat to the elite and they're just
hoping they were hoping with Bloomberg
and I think a lot of the polls that we
saw were before the debates a lot of
people were hoping that Bloomberg out of
the moderate group would be the one that
would finally light people up would be
the one that would finally have a
momentum momentum or movement behind him
they thought he would be a lot more
inspiring turns out he's not so they're
sitting with what four different
moderates at this point people are
splitting the vote between those four
moderates there's not a clear winner out
of those four moderates Bernie Sanders
has emerged as a clear winner on there
on the progressive side Elizabeth Warren
I think last night helped I think on the
debates Elizabeth Warren helped Bernie
Sanders with that because I think that
she essentially took away I think she
exposed Michael Bloomberg and this
helped Bernie I think because Elizabeth
Warren is gonna rise up in the polls
people are gonna be more endeared to her
and ultimately she's gonna end up giving
her delegates over to Bernie Sanders
so the moderates on the other hand they
don't have anybody running away with
this I still think it's gonna be booted
judge I don't think this is gonna be a
bite and Bernie fight I mean if I move
that bite and Bernie you want to jump in
there Zack cam if I may I also don't
think yeah I'm curious Kim I also don't
think they're gonna let Bernie actually
end up being the nominee maybe Budaj
edge seems possible but what would you
say to all the disenchanted Bernie
Sanders supporters which basically Dean
that watch the primary gets stolen from
them yeah if Trump has been calling that
out Trump is the only person who has
been soberly commenting on how Sanders
had the nomination pulled out from under
him literally Trump is the only person
Bernie won't even admit it in the
bate he called it Russia yet again
Hillary is still parroting that lie we
all know it's a lie how do you do
anybody recently think Bernie could take
on Trump while Trump is talking the
truth and Bernie is lying about what
happened to him one of the things I
think is very very interesting here and
we go to Moloch on this year after
Bloomberg's performance and what what
we've seen witnessed him do with his
money but basically pay people that will
say and do anything okay shamelessly all
right
but what that debate did is allow people
Democrats to vote for Bernie now it's
okay now you've been given permission
now okay and that this is not what the
DNC wanted of course but after that
people that had these lingering thoughts
about Bernie they saw that whole field
the bickering the pettiness and and then
the new DNC guy you know is cardboard as
he it is all of a sudden Bernie you have
permission it's okay now that's what
they have done
the DNC strikes again go ahead Malik
hater love Bernie Bernie is who he has
been for as long as we've known Bernie
and that's one of the things that many
people like about him he's a fighter
he's consistent in that one person that
we really haven't talked about is Joe
Biden and too well but I don't think
that I'm but I don't think we should
necessarily I don't think we should
necessarily cancel Biden out just yet I
mean we do have to wait into a Super
Tuesday and remember again that
Bloomberg is not on the ballot until
super it is Tuesday but I think there
too there is going to be a huge
generational gap and Bernie supporter
versus Bloomberg supporters versus Biden
supporters and it will be interesting to
see after we get past South Carolina how
well Bloomberg does anywhere because I
don't know who Bloomberg's natural
constituency is as far as Bernie I can
clearly identify them as far as Biden I
can clearly identify them but would
Bloomberg I don't know who his natural
consistency is and so I don't think that
he's going to do very well
they all they all work on Wall Street
okay that's his constituency okay okay
Kim I guess and I think Klobuchar is in
the sunset right now I think Warren
tried to make up for her screw up with
as insulting Bernie Sanders of being
misogynist that was a huge mistake on
her part and I think she and she really
alienated a lot of people so that now we
get to one the last person I want to
talk about food Pete Buddha judge
where's he in all of this okay because
he doesn't have the ground game he's not
really good at retail politics but he's
still liked by the media go ahead Kim
yeah I actually still think he is the
moderate to watch I still think he has
more of a if you want to call it a
movement behind him in some ways people
are more fired up about him they want to
see somebody younger they want to see
somebody who is fresh I think he's the
Emmanuel macron of the United States and
I think it really says a lot on the DNC
tried to put everybody against Sanders
you know they've had they tried Biden Oh
Biden's gonna be the savior you know
everybody's at the kiddie table and then
they said okay now only look oh maybe
it's Buddha judge'll maybe it's clear
Bashar or maybe it's Bloomberg I still
ultimately think out of those four
candidates the one who has the most fire
behind them is actually Buddha judge
when it comes down to the voters this is
why the media is wrong okay the sack but
I mean again there's good to be the
perception real or imagined among Bernie
supporters that the DNC is going to
throw all their fire behind this mayor
Pete and there's gonna be again that
sense of being cheated okay and like I
said real or imagined in this in this in
this race okay I think it was obvious in
2016 but the way the DNC you know
Bloomberg gives them a ton of money they
all of a sudden changed the rules we all
know that that's a fact okay
now if the DNC pushes all the way behind
mayor Pete there's gonna be a sense of
alienation and it will suppress the vote
one minute goes to you Zach go ahead
that's right and you know Buddha Jed's
you know he's always been smarmy but I
thought in this recent debate he was
particularly insufferable I don't think
that he's gonna win a lot of people over
although I do agree that he does kind of
have this naive sense of Oh someone new
so
one young but that's really you know the
media is certainly making out the whole
Democratic Party to be much bigger than
it is and much you know the you look at
the Trump rallies it's shocking to see
some of these lines outside Trump
rallies in New Jersey blue states you
know there is going to be so many
Democrats voting Republican this time
around you know the Democrats aren't
gonna have anyone that really can
compete to be honest I'll say it now
but it could be Buddha judge it does
just seem to me the most obviously clear
thing is that it's not gonna be Bernie
they're not gonna let him have it and
you know could be Buddha judge I think
Biden has fossilized I don't think he's
going anywhere and you know Bloomberg he
does have the name recognition from his
media empire that I do think looks
attractive to them in the general
election will he make it there will he
be able to buy his way there I don't
know I'm gonna end on on Kim's
observation if the Democratic Party
respected voters they might have a
chance in November but they haven't
shown that respect that's all the time
we have many thanks to my guests in
Washington Seattle and in Los Angeles
and thanks to our viewers for watching
us here at RT see you next time and
remember crosscut rules
[Music]